thanks again to libs of tiktok
one of my favorite twitter accounts
which i suspect is going to get even
more of a boost now that now that the uh
left is not suppressing conservatives
accounts quite as much
a libs of tick tock posted a video of a
teacher playing a slideshow about how he
is going to indoctrinate kids into
transgenderism it opens up it says just
this quote stop brainwashing our
children in the classroom with the lgbt
agenda the teacher kind of looks and
smiles and laughs
it says ms beamon is now mix beamon
you know me as ms beamon i'm still your
teacher but now i'm mixed beam because
i'm non-gendered now and i'll go by he
and they and i'm transgender and
non-binary and i'm the same me but we're
going to work together so that you can
recognize that i'm not just a boy or a
girl what's transgender what's
non-binary it's where you look like one
thing but you're actually a different
sex on the inside and that's why i've
got to be mix now mx rather than mr or
ms or mrs or miss really
because that's what transgenderism says
and transgenderism is true
that's just i i did give the quick
version because it's tick-tock so
they're moving very quickly
but that's what a teacher is teaching
five-year-olds i actually i don't know
what
what level of student this teacher is
teaching whether it's a five-year-old or
whether it's an 18 year old for that
matter
it's just not true
right now go to dealdash.com
knowles whether you are in the market
for a basic kitchen appliance or a
luxury upgrade to your old tv deal dash
will allow you to get the best deals on
whatever you're looking for dealdash
partners with brands of all sizes
wholesalers and inventory liquidators
when these brands are stuck with excess
inventory they can't sell deal dash
helps out by buying these excess lots
and can pass on big savings to its
customers on brand new high quality
products deal dash has hundreds of
auctions daily on brand new items
ranging from laptops and tvs to tools
and kitchenware even cars with
guaranteed free shipping ipads have sold
for 33.60
brand new cars have sold for less than
one thousand dollars in addition
in order to keep these prices low deal
dash charges a small fee to place a bid
you can always buy the product at the
buy it now price to get the credits back
that you used in the auction and then
you can reuse them in later auctions all
auctions start at zero dollars you have
a 90 day money back guarantee on your
first bid pack purchase do not be made a
victim in today's inflation get all the
products you desire without price hikes
at deal dash today use promo code
knowles knwles for an additional 100
free bids when making your first bid
pack purchase and start bidding
dealdash.com
knowles
the teacher is saying that
transgenderism is real that you can
really secretly be the opposite sex that
you should call people by this made-up
prefix mix
and that
she is now really a he or they and
that's not true
her name is they because they are legion
or something no that's none of that is
true and the teacher should be fired or
put into counseling i mean the teacher
should be probably placed on leave told
to go see a psychiatrist psychologist
unfortunately these days the
psychologist will just affirm this woman
in her delusions and but if the
psychologist somehow could convince the
woman that she really is a woman and she
realizes that she was deluded before
then maybe she could come back and teach
the kids but if she if she's not going
to be convinced of reality and she's
going to insist on peddling destructive
falsehoods in the classroom then you got
to fire her
because she's harming kids education and
she has no right to do that
it's not an act of cruelty to do that
it's it's actually an act of compassion
to the students and compassion to her
because the further down this rabbit
hole of fantasy she gets the worse off
she's going to be people don't
flourish when they are totally
untethered from reality
got to
get a little tougher because sometimes
getting tougher is more loving that's
that's what we call tough love
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications head on over also to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
and type in
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]